what we have seen in europe is a perfect
storm after the covet pandemic in which
aviation was crushed and many people
left the industry it's bounced back more
quickly than anybody could have imagined
that's the result of of course very
strong demand to make up for lost
sunshine particularly among europeans
who are desperate to get their vacations
unfortunately
during the dark days of travel
restrictions many great people left the
travel industry the aviation industry
and there simply aren't the people and
the skills um to cope with the demand
the airlines meanwhile they have picked
up billions of dollars in debt over the
past two years they desperately want to
pay them down and i think they've been
over optimistic in what they have been
promising and selling simply because
it's great to get cash through the door
aviation has always required a vast
number of people in all sorts of roles
and while pilots have generally got well
paid um unfortunately the same can't be
said for a lot of the staff for instance
who work at ground handling
companies at the airports now these
people are really essential but they
have simply not been paid enough to keep
them in the industry or to attract
newcomers in every summer in europe you
will get industrial action but we're
actually seeing much more than this
we've got pilots in scandinavia we've
got refuellers at london heath road
baggage handlers can almost name their
price anywhere in europe as
understandably workers sense that this
is the time to press home their
advantage um because any part of the
aviation chain if people walk out on
strike then everything can seize up the
economic power that the unions have i
think they are testing to the maximum
while any industry of course thrives on
new blood coming in great new people
particularly younger people who want a
career in aviation they can't get
through the system and properly trained
and security cleared in time to uh cope
with the incredible demands of a
european stomach in order to get you and
your baggage safely to your destination
everything needs to go right it's an
incredible act of choreography involving
aviation professionals if one of those
elements is not where it should be when
it needs to be there things can start to
unravel very quickly so wherever you're
heading this summer in europe hope for
the best but be prepared for delay and
disruption